[موسيقى]
وآمل حقًا أن يخرجوني قريبًا
بعيدًا لأنني حقًا أفتقد عائلتي
وإلى الأصدقاء، شيء آخر لعائلتي، أبي، رافيف، أمي
إيريس توفا لا نويا توم نوجي حياتي
أفتقدك إلى ما لا نهاية وسوف أراك قريبا
أنا قوي وسنعود جميعًا وكل شيء سيكون على ما يرام
للتحدث مع أختي التي كانت لديها قبل أسبوعين
عيد ميلاد سعيد وأريد أن أتمنى لها عيد ميلاد سعيد
آمل أن تكون بخير وعلى قيد الحياة
بسلام وأتمنى أن أخرج من هنا قبل اليوم
عيد ميلاد والدتي ينتظر عناقًا منكم جميعًا
أحبك أثناء خدمتي السحرية
عني وعن كل ما أحتاجه، أحتاج إلى الطعام
وكل ما أود قوله هو أن أشيد بك
سلوك القوات السحرية
الذي عاملني باحترام وحتى اعتنى بي
خاطروا بحياتهم لحمايتي من
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الصواريخ وكل يوم هناك حتى المنزل الذي كنا فيه
هو نفسه تعرض للقصف، ولحسن الحظ خرجنا، كنت في الثالثة من عمري
منازل تم قصف ثلاثة منازل من قبل هال
[موسيقى]
الهواء أريد أن أعطي رسالة إلى بنيامين
رأس نتنياهو
الحكومة ستوقف الحرب والصواريخ لن تفعل ذلك
سوف يؤذيني ويلحق بالمختطفين الآخرين الموجودين هنا في غزة
ونريد العودة إلى المنزل مرحباً وأريد ذلك
ليقول من فضلك أوقف الحرب من فضلك ولنا
نريد العودة إلى ديارنا بأمان
سلام